I had a family come backstage one time
with their grandmother like older woman
and and they were all very nice and like
there was a pause and she said so how
long have you been in vaudeville I guess
since 1910 I don't I don't how to answer
that question
[Music]
having kids is a good way to make good
decisions to like force yourself into
good decisions did you find that like it
really got you to well I mean as soon as
I knew our son was gonna be born I you
know that's when I got life insurance
and all that sort of thing you know
because it's like it's not about you
anymore it's like there's this other
human being who who demands that I be a
better person than I am prior to knowing
that I have a child coming but it forces
you to step up to the plate you know you
meet people out on the road and
especially right after your first child
is born and they go I've got a little
one at home too and then they show you a
picture of their dog Oh what it's always
like there you go are we really talking
about the same thing or your baby is
very but you go you're trying to be
polite well so we were sharing in this
thing little baby human yeah the whole
dog has babies things I mean my dogs
definitely gave me a new sort of
responsibility that I didn't feel prior
to having dogs but I would never put
them on the same level as that and even
I will go as far to say wouldn't someone
when I talk about having dogs and then
someone comes up and shows me a picture
of their dog I don't care I've ever seen
a dog that I've really been like wow you
know yeah sorry Noah show me their dogs
I I know you don't care about my dog and
I still even when I'm showing the
picture I dunno yeah you tell you
there's no
you care it's hard to be taken aback at
a photo of a dog it's unless they're
doing something I think it'd be easier
for me with the dog than the baby like
I'm a stranger showing you their baby
it's like yeah that's just another
stranger you're showing me which is
weird yeah I mean I get that like I
remember looking at pictures of babies
before I had one no why are you showing
me what am I supposed to say yeah it's a
day old it's got a like a hat on and a
blanket and I I just see this squished
up face what do you want me to say what
is the best just because I always hit
that scenario with someone showing me a
newborn baby and I go you haven't
prepared for that you you know this is
coming mm-hmm let's think of some like
what are the best looks fresh they don't
look like a parent so you can't be like
oh she looks so rested maybe some way
bad but then you go to the other extreme
you know where when it's your kid it's a
whole different thing and I remember
looking at the sonogram pictures of my
son and going I think he kinda looks
like and I already see a resemblance you
know so yeah I just go I can only
imagine what this means to you like I
just like I just I acknowledge that this
is something that I can't possibly
understand how much you love showing me
this picture right now but I'm just so
happy for you that you're feeling that
new dad like that's that's good cuz you
can't get there yeah cuz it's just
and everyone was a baby every single
person has been a baby and had people go
home oh like everyone and that I was
thinking about that like I did stand-up
bit about it but like every baby is just
gonna be some guy ya know weird when you
look at a little baby you know one day
that
maybe holding an attache case little
baby's gonna have a three-piece suit on
and the baby's gonna be in line at
t.j.maxx someday right debating over
that weird popcorn they have you can be
looking at a baby and think at some
point in that baby's life he's gonna be
saying or like any little girl whenever
I see a little girl that's just like
full of wonder and adorable I'm just
like she one day is gonna be like why
isn't he texting me back like I do I
just feel I want to just grab little
girls and be like it's gonna be okay
like yeah you're gonna go through so
much and I know boys go through
heartbreak too but for some reason
little girls I'm just like you're gonna
get screwed over so much and I want to
warn them we're supposed to text people
back if you don't know who Brian Regan
is what is wrong with you right Chad
sumac I think every young comic or every
comic has googled Brian Regan we've all
watched you just learning how we still
should not watch as a new comic because
it will depress you so much yeah because
you will compare yourself and you'll say
I will never be that and it's one of
those people like he's one of those
people that everyone becomes obsessed
with so early on because he is the best
and then you get even now as as a comic
who's been doing it 16 years I watch him
and I get to press so you got to pick
and choose because I'm just like I will
never be that that is how great Brian
Regan is I'm sorry to dislike and but I
just love you and I'm so excited that
you're here that is very very kind I'm
worried that no matter what I say next
yep
people at home where to go that didn't
sound very funny no that's incredibly
kind words it's thank you very much you
know Ron Ron bennington the great Ron
bet the great Ron bennington he thought
it would be funny one time to bring
me up with an intro that no one could
possibly follow so he said ladies this
is a comedy club he goes ladies and
gentlemen this next comedian I don't
know how to say this but I'm telling you
right now within 10 seconds you will
literally fall off your chairs at the
top of your lungs I guarantee you of
course bomb definitely you know like how
can you possibly follow that one of the
worst intros I ever heard and I'll never
forget it because as soon as I heard it
I was like remember this forever was in
Mason City Illinois the smallest old
like it's not around anymore
I mean this town was literally a couple
hundred people in this town in Illinois
and the guy brought up a guest button he
goes hey this next guy just sent off a
tape to Letterman and we wish him a lot
of luck with that an emcee asked a
comedian what should I say about you and
the guy said tell him that I'm this was
back when Star Search was on tell him
that I might be auditioning for Scott in
six months wow this guy he might be
auditioning for Star Search in six
months he hasn't made up his mind but it
might happen it might happen that he
might audition for Star Search I got one
the other day when this guy was like
alright you next time I've actually
never heard of this guy no easy but I've
heard he's good yeah
Richi Minervini very funny comedian from
Long Island when I first went out on the
road he had told me hey if he because he
ran a club in Long Island he said if he
ever in town give me a call so I decided
to go out and try to get into comedy
clubs and I gave him a call and there
was a bunch of comedians on the show and
he gets onstage and his intro of me was
you know how like sometimes you come
across somebody you meet them and you
say hey man if you're in town give me a
call and then you expect like that's
kind of the end of that that's true I
mean that most the time when you say hey
cuz I do that a lot to comics I meet on
the road I go if MCS I work with and I
go if you ever want to guest set or if
I'm ever in a town where you happen to
be you got one like just follow up and I
really do mean it but so few people
actually are the squeaky wheel and ask
for things when there's opportunities
and I think that that's and when people
do ask me for things I always go at
least give him one shot I'll go yeah
like even if I've never heard of you for
a guest that if I can give it I will
give it because I like people who asks
for ask for things and and believe in
themselves what were you like that
coming up did you it sounds like if
there was an opportunity you called you
would drive out of your way to go do
gigs yeah well I'm gonna date myself but
when I first went out to try to get into
comedy clubs you had to go to the club
yeah you know there was no this was pre
VHS tape Wow I remember when VHS tapes
came around and people were going now
you can just send a tape but I'm like
you gotta be kidding me I literally
would take Greyhound buses to every
comedy club I could get to and go on and
just do a guest set and see if they
would book me yeah you know and but it
was thrilling I mean that was part of
what was thrilling I'm like I'm a young
guy and I'm taking buses to these little
obscure towns and going on at the
Chuckle house and some goofy little city
and seeing if they'd book me you know so
that's how I had to do it I agree I
think I look back so often on those
bus trips and staying in comedy condos
and showing up at clubs and not knowing
why describe my career I mean you look
back and you go
it didn't seem bad back then people can
kind of struggling on the road but it
never felt like work now doing that I
would never do those things because my
time is worth more but it it back then
it was it never felt it was exciting it
was fun and it was what we love to do
right cuz you don't you know it's
adventurous I remember being on an
overnight Greyhound bus you know and
you're just sitting there and your brain
is going off in a million different
directions and I could hear the woman
behind me talking to the guy next to her
I was like 3 in the morning and she said
I know my brother killed somebody
[Laughter]
am I supposed to get up and go to the
bus driver and go ahead call the police
or do I just let this go and I let it go
and I think I'm the one that could have
put that put that guy away the people
you would count the weirdos some of the
conversations because yeah it was just
thinking of you and those buses back
then I mean yesterday I went to the
airport I had a full day of travel with
a connection you know I left my flight
was at 7:30 leaving LA got into New York
at 7 o'clock at night but I right before
I got I checked my bags I wanted to like
add some stuff to my luggage so you know
I take it out and I put it all in and I
checked my luggage and I'm going through
security and I'm like oh where's my
phone oh no oh no I somehow I just knew
that it was in my luggage that's checked
and I'm like I have to go this whole day
without my phone and thankfully I went I
didn't know this you can go back to the
desk and they will go rummage through
your luggage for you if you tell them
good tip I thought it was long gone I
was like well I'm just gonna go
throughout my day without it and
hopefully connect like on the plane like
be able to get my blue
I'd rather lose a family member than my
phone I'm being honest it's it feels
that devastating but I was kind of
accepting like I'm just gonna go through
my day without podcasts or my white
noise machine everything that's on my
phone but that's used to be the way I
mean you were just alone with your
thoughts yeah I'm listening to people
and listening to people yeah I mean I
remember being on one of those long
Greyhound rides I mean I'm saying
some of these bus rides longer than 30
day 30 day America's you would could go
anywhere Greyhound would go for 30 days
for one price that's cool and I remember
one time just exhausted sitting in the
and the chair there not not super
comfortable and thinking to myself if
like any time I wouldn't be able to
sleep in the future in a bed that I
would remember that moment because at
the time all I wanted to do was lie down
I go I get to lie down every other day
of my life and I don't realize what a
luxury it is so I'm going to use this
moment to realize what a luxury that is
in the future and I do that from time to
time where I go I'm not on a Greyhound
bus I love that and I thought that same
thing yesterday when I had a long day of
travel where you just sit on your ass
all day so you go why am i exhausted
from this you know like don't let
yourself be exhausted but I got home and
I was laying in bed and I was like
laying down is made to do that all day
and that's why I deserve this right now
because I had to be upright and that is
so fun I love that you I think that's
important when you're in a comfortable
situation that you don't want to be in
mark it in your head is like when I
don't have to be in this situation
really enjoy it and that's how you can
get through the other day I was
breathing good I didn't enjoy it at all
how about like when you're young and
your older brother holds you underwater
you know you're like all I want to do is
breathe could you imagine like if every
breath when you did come up for the rest
of your life you just say celebrate it
with the most ecstatic joy appreciate it
I just came up with an idea yes I'm
gonna pitch it to you right now oh your
Netflix I know you have one coming out
mm-hmm executive produced by Jerry
Seinfeld Brian Regan back to basics you
go back to the comedy condo you go back
to the Greyhounds you open up an emcee
shows at the funny bones document it
sounds awesome right someone else get
the feeling we're going to switch places
[Laughter]
[Music]
you